when you say in the book hey
the great love of my life was renee
zellweger
you say it jim carrey the character but
i'm assuming
that that's true and she was special to
me very special
i think she's lovely i got kind of sad
it was like wow jim's saying in the book
again you know
it's you have poetic license because
it's fiction but you know you're saying
man
the great love of my life was renee
zellweger and that was quite some time
ago
and it was almost like you were saying i
shouldn't have [ __ ] that up like that
was the one that
whatever happened the one that got away
i don't regret i don't have those things
uh but but i i do appreciate the people
that have come through my life for
for the good that that they gave me and
and uh
and that's why linda ronstadt has a
special place in the book
because you know it it may have seemed
like some
you know boy toy kind of situation to
some people looking at it from the
outside but she treated me with
incredible respect and she loved my
talent
and respected my talent and we used to
hang out together and she'd say
you're going to be where i am you're
going to deal with all the stuff i've
dealt with when i was reading the book i
was reminding me i forgot about that
whole linda ronstadt thing
but i don't find for anybody i don't
pine for anybody you know
it's really that kind of situation it's
it's just my way of saying there was a
very
important thing there you know and to
recognize that
it is amazing that she saw you and
didn't say
oh there's the lowly jim carrey i can't
uh be with him
she had this beautiful love she was so
cool i gotta tell you
so the the the night we met was at uh
the comedy store
and i
heard that linda ronstadt needed an
opening act
and so i i did my show in the original
room and i got a standing ovation
i was i really slaughtered the room
and i went outside and i don't know what
i was thinking
i was just in like 21 year old mack
daddy mode i don't know what the hell it
was
that possessed me but i just immediately
just
was adored her and uh
she came up and she said wow you're
really good would you like to come on
the road with me
and i said no but i'll go out with you
wow
ballsy like without a without a thought
just like no but i'll go out with you so
i was giving up a gig which i needed i
had no money
and uh she kind of screwed up her face
and she said
okay
you